attention la vidéo vous vous apprêtez à
voir est disponible en 720p
ce qui est totalement inutile surtout
pas le sexe les caennais au frente est
ce que c'est normal qu'un jeu et ce sont
les suivantes dégueulasse enfin bon il
faut voir la gueule du menu pardon
pardon pardon c'est vrai c'est vrai bon
allez on commence tout de suite ce jeu
un start mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça
ok y en a qui nettoie avec la souris
allez allez allez watch avait eu
d'arrivée mais qu'est ce qu'elle fout
est ce que ce jeu un sens mais what may
a arrêté j'ai déjà joué déjà je ne vous
permet pas on a aujourd'hui les
bruitages l'epu ouf du monde en même
temps si on fait le jeu avec des
bruitages réalistes comme ça et c'est
comme si on faisait un mélange de rendre
hauts et de bas et voici un jeu pour
vous mesdames que regarder mes vidéos
vous qui êtes à peu près 3 sur cent
mille personnes qui regardent mes vidéos
good old band le jeu qui va vous
apprendre à être un excellent mari alors
on est un [ __ ] de cuba alors déjà ce
qu'ils sont c'est super ce sens parce
que je crois que on ne verra jamais la
tête de cet homme
un quoi qu'il arrive voilà on ne sera
jamais à quoi ressemble donc on ne sera
jamais la tête qu'à un bon mari 1 c'est
à dire qui peut ressembler à ça oui si
vous voulez être un bon mari passer la
tondeuse mesdames vous voulez un bon
mari si c'est de passer la tondeuse
alors ici vivent dans une sorte de
paradis à
totalement linéaire ne voulait rien dire
à les poubelles peut-être oui attention'
on va mettre ça dans la poubelle la
voile à 175 moi je suis un excellent
mari space 2 bis au non non non non mon
dieu ça veut dire que que l'homme
parfait ressemble à ça wes studi oui
sans faille wife leave me alone morceau
niang va t'en vas te rende utile mais
l'espoir démarche en train de [ __ ]
tout mais poids regardez mes points et
elle a toujours pas voulu me laisser
regarder la télé si on peut la butte et
je le fais nous allons aujourd'hui en
exclusivité mondiale tenté de muscler
mon petit corps de lâches
j'ai mangé 20 kilos de protéines je n'ai
pas fait caca depuis 58 jours à ce
moment puisque dans le jeu j'en fais à
peu près 50 milles mais dans la vraie
vie je ferai juste ça oui j'en ai faire
voilà j'en ai vu je sens les muscles je
sens les muscles qui a évolué jeune
petit maigre est passé en gros mais bien
musclé viril sur le jeu rame à 10
millions 2010 2% alors ce jeu là
s'appelle moutons qui va dans l'espace
vous ai déjà vu un mouton qui fait un
tué rck
quoi oh mon dieu c'est parce que l'or va
dans l'espace et la même musique que si
on était dans un ascenseur pour monter
au deuxième étage d'une tour non là
c'est dans l'espace je crois que nous
arrivons sur une planète
rosa autrement plaît il y avait un
canapé bon alors on va lancer ce jeu
lula avec une icône de bananes set
partout 6 fonctionner mais c'est mal
attendait le jeu est tellement nul que
il crache quand tu lances ce jeu
s'appelle je dois sauver le monde
alors on va voir de quelle de quelle
façon ils veulent sauver le monde
on s'éclate à je sauve le monde
aw l amusement ou pas alors ce jeu
s'appelle un truc comme taper sur les
punks je crois qui ressemble à ça alors
on va défoncer ces petits bonhommes rose
un homme de bh oui d'accord pour dire
que ce mec c'est comme si hulk était
désormais rose
alors si dans la vraie vie coach table
quelqu'un qui se passe ça quand je pense
que on va devenir copains très vite
oui est ce que il ya eu un quelconque
message éducatif à travers ce jeu fa oui
fuck bas dans la tête ça doit être ça la
morale de jeu et aujourd'hui nous sommes
sur un jeu très apprécié des chimpanzés
des macaques puisqu'il faut [ __ ] de
click est comme un gros mois sur cette
[ __ ] de balade
on est d'accord pour dire que le mec a
créé jour ressembler à ça
j'adore les bananes moi j'adore les
bananes un ouais c'est bon on a assez
pour nourrir les singes du zoo de
beauval pendant 123 année alors
apparemment d'enjeux faut cliquer sur
les mots c'est de mettre était un
accident of the sky à petit bruit à
joséphine ange gardien ouais tu où es tu
non mais bien parce uni je veux voir
quand la barben extrémités ce que ça
donne
c'est incroyable ce qui se passe on
observe un enchaînement de trois images
par seconde
aujourd'hui coup c'est un jeu powered by
unity qui est un moteur souvent utilisé
dans les jambes et déjà un député par
balle alors que les playes watts à ces
lanternes
mais qu'est-ce que j'ai l'âge et un
marteau et un coût mais qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire je vous rends pas une sorte
de sneijder en version attendue mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ça mais qui tue
que veux-tu [ __ ] mais j'ai peur pour
les jca c'est tellement nul que j'ai
peur qu'est ce qui se passe là pourquoi
pourquoi je suis en une fois mille mais
matt est juste le niveau du [ __ ] de
zoom wata wata fuck
ok d'accord c'était le meilleur jeu de
la planète terre
car mercredi les bienvenus la suze
bretelles
en fait je suis dans une église d'accord
mesdames et messieurs ce soir nous
faisons